before i dive into this frankly
outrageously brilliant arc i want to say
that if you're interested in what manga
i'll be tackling in my next blind review
series stay tuned because at some point
in this video i'll be making that big
announcement but for now let's dive into
berserk's incredible and haunting lost
children arc
[Music]
the lost children arc is a story unlike
any other contained within berserk in
most other sections of this sprawling
tragedy miura allows us to view guts as
the backbone of each part however in
this guts isn't the backbone and i
wouldn't even say he's the main
protagonist in fact speaking
specifically about the foundations of
this arc no one character fulfills that
role in my view but instead what anchors
this narrative is a fairy tale of sorts
a piece of folklore that brings with it
an interesting angle for which to view
this story through so i think in order
to understand this arc you must first
understand its fairy tale peace the
outcast something that came as a shock
to me while i was reading this was how
similar the structure was to one of my
favorite one piece arcs skypia i'm not
going to spoil the story of skype yet
but one aspect that these two stories
share is the legend or fairy tale
present in their respective stories
which dictates what happens later either
thematically or literally in the case of
one piece it's the story of noland and
in the case of lost children it's the
tale of pcaf the outcast occupying
roughly two and a half pages in the
entire arc pikaf's story tells a tale of
a young village boy with two loving
parents however sporting two pointy ears
and red eyes he finds himself alienated
from the rest of his community routinely
bullied by the other children one night
however in search of his real family
picaff ran into the forest looking for
where the elves lived where grownups
never said to go eventually he found the
elves but not the family he was seeking
picaff didn't have wings and was
honestly quite different to the elves he
sought community with they did however
tell him that one night many many years
ago a mother and father ventured into
the woods to save their sick child they
managed to save him with their magic but
in exchange changed his appearance to
half resemble that of the elves learning
this with great haste he ran off back to
the village only to find that 100 years
had passed in the moments he was away
left alone peak half the outcast cried
and cried his red eyes swollen even
redder the moral of the story is simple
to understand in isolation but it's how
miura leverages this story and explores
its themes and potential messaging in
this broader story with two of its key
characters jill a young girl rescued at
the beginning by guts and eventually
another young girl called rosine
one of the first things you'll notice in
this story is how different it feels
from all the others and it achieves this
through guts's relinquishing his
position as the main character instead
placing this role as the young girl with
a troubled family situation called jill
and the reason i see her as the main
character is that there are large
portions of it told through her point of
view specifically for instance there's a
tremendous amount of narration
surrounding jill and guts's first
meeting when he rescues her from some
bandits and kidnappers already this sets
a different tone but what really makes
this strange is how he's often referred
to as the black swordsman or just
swordsman instead of guts his name with
this very introduction she has two guts
framed as our own to the character also
in another scene after gutz brings her
home he's shown a quiet place to rest
but when we return to that scene the
next morning we find that we didn't
spend the night with him and instead
jill it's her point of view and story
that this tale is concerned with we
return to guts having clearly spent a
night fighting monsters only for jill to
stumble upon the aftermath jill is our
point of view character guts is just the
catalyst for the chaos that ensues
immediately after this moment when we
get the first meeting between the two
main characters the protagonist jill and
the antagonist rosine interestingly and
in keeping with the story doing things
just a little bit different instead of
guts being held responsible for the
action taking place in this arc it's
pock and his elven appearance that's
held responsible and the reason is
obviously this girl i've been talking
about called rosine oh and by the way
did i mention that she's a weird moth
monster this is one of the two
antagonists of the ark and one of the
most important elements of the story to
our main protagonist in jill and i'd
like to talk about why this is cool now
but instead right in the middle of the
story we get this weird one-shot chapter
called the prototype in the hardback
deluxe edition i'm reading berserk the
prototype this story is a submission
piece created by kintara miura during
his stay in college in 1988 which became
his basis for what is now called the
series berserk the establishment of
certain details world view and whatnot
differs at points from the berserk
series that was later published but the
intent is still present in this early
incarnation the most noticeable
difference right away is how much looser
and art style the pages and characters
are drawn with it still looks like
berserk but with a greater emphasis on
expression over the detail he would
become later known for however in
addition to that this manga carries with
it a great sin one which i i don't think
i can forgive for when guts is requested
by an old woman to avenge her
granddaughter he refuses in a way that
makes my very skin crawl confidently he
responds i've got nothing to do with
just and generous chivalry i could care
less i can't believe you've done this to
borrow a quote from david mitchell i
could care less is absolutely useless as
an indicator of how much you care
because the only thing that it rules out
is that you don't care at all which is
exactly what you're trying to convey and
let's be clear here for one moment i
don't blame miura for a second but i do
blame whoever localized the version i'm
reading into english translation is a
tough business i'm sure but one thing
i'm supposed to be able to take for
granted when someone translates into
english is that they know how to speak
[ __ ] english
i award you no points
and may god have mercy on your soul
and now i'm realizing that i've spoken
about literally one tiny line more than
the chapter itself in broad strokes this
chapter while having a few details
changed here and there highlights how
much of the story miura was settled on
even before the story began branding's
the design of which is only minorly
changed his appearance and the eclipse
over the castle a shot that is etched
into my mind so deep i'm convinced years
of therapy won't remove it and of course
the character of puck the flavor of
berserk is very clearly present as well
as miura's approach with guts as a
character being a selfish tough guy
that's pretty bad at being selfish
decent chapter overall nothing
groundbreaking but if you're a fan of
the series you will absolutely get a
kick out of this and now back to the
main story in the past miura has
described this story and the broader
conviction arc as a sakaike or world
type story the simple definition of a
sekaike's story is the existence of a
close relationship between two people
which turns out to be the sole driving
force of the events up to and including
having all other happenings in the world
at large depending on said
relationship's fate whether
metaphorically or literally within the
broader conviction eric muir is
obviously alluding to the relationship
between guts and puck which too plays a
massive role in these events surrounding
lost children particularly the ending
but the relationship in question that
influences the path of lost children
specifically is that which exists
between the characters of jill our
protagonist and rosine her friend and
the antagonist of this story something
miura does a fantastic job of with this
chapter is managing the audience's
expectations we're made aware of
everyone's biases experiences and how
their perception of the character guts
changes and morphs over the narrative
and it's most effective when we finally
see the image of the children now
corpses in a burning barn after changing
back once they die at the hands of guts
worth noting here though is that they
actually attacked him first they weren't
children and were in fact monster bug
creatures embodied with the spirit of
children lost from the village but try
telling that to the parents they see a
pile of child corpses and all of a
sudden everyone's up in arms it's very
like kintara miura to really hammer home
just how bad a situation is by making it
stand beside significantly less
harrowing material i mean there's a page
during the chapter entitled red eye
peace where in a small fire a child
reaches out to guts asking for his mommy
and cuts just cleaves this young guy in
twain like it's really brutal stuff but
it comes immediately after seeing a
heart to heart with jill and puck
following close behind him jill's
recounting of a backstory concerning her
one time friend rosine however is
interesting for a number of reasons i
really like how these brief moments of
reflection add more color to this
already black world making it feel all
the more lived in but when she brings up
the beheld it rosine found my mind began
to wonder those things seem to seek out
those that are in tremendous pain or
perhaps individuals with promise
certainly not the same level of promise
griffith had but it did give me a moment
for pause this rogue elf creature is in
fact rosine after all and she fell to
the battle it which means there's reason
to believe that the person she was once
still resides somewhere deep down as she
yielded her attack once jill placed
herself in between guts and herself
making me stop to think for a second i
wonder if the person griffith is is
still there and if he is is it someone
that would have compassion for anyone is
anything more important to him than his
current conquest my guess would be no
but who's to say for sure i have no idea
what's to come in the story
what are you doing do you think we
should pick him up
he's got a knife
but he's got g fuel and a knife
i'm sure there's a reason
hey buddy
what's with the knife
it's for uh
mexican
[Music]
knives
say
[Music]
believe it
i want to keep this section brief as
it's sort of an aside to the main focus
of this story instead picking up on the
broader significance of certain aspects
that came to my attention while reading
this arc concerning the character of
rosine she seems to have appeared during
the eclipse in front of rickert which
creates i suppose a natural segue into
me pointing out my acknowledgement of
other apostles that have appeared in
other arcs like the snake man from
chapter one the trouble count from the
end of the black swordsman arc and of
course the apostle that killed corkus it
was the one guts obliterated in the very
first pages of book one oh and by the
way i'd like to thank the commenter that
pointed that out to us a while back we
definitely would have missed that had
you not pointed that out to us so thank
you additionally and perhaps most
importantly concerning the present story
we're exploring in this video something
happens between guts and pop that's
perhaps the most overt and explicit
example of there being a fate that's
drawing them towards each other having
had a falling out and going their
separate ways part ways through the
midpoint of this arc puck seemingly
without his knowledge is drawn back
inadvertently to the area guts is
heading the misty valley where rosine
has brought jill i still don't fully
understand what this means in the long
term but it's definitely interesting to
see how it might develop and with jill
now having been kidnapped and taken by
rosine into her land of the elves in
this misty valley guts is slaughtering
his way to rosine without her knowledge
there's a collision course after being
set so let's discuss the climax and the
ending of this arc the lost children arc
is a story about coping with trauma jill
and rosine two young girls and in many
ways are point of view antagonist and
protagonist of the ark unlike previous
arcs in this story guts has seen less
like the central character and reality
more like the opposing force of
antagonism to the events that transpire
it's honestly fascinating and yet the
paradise roseanne creates for herself
turns into a flaming hellscape
[Applause]
[Music]
in this climax the action is insane the
visuals are ridiculously beautiful and
harrowing and guts really brings the
intensity and he is very much the
pressure onto the evil in this story but
in the end he reveals that he isn't the
answer that jill is looking for the
salvation she desires from the torment
of her upbringing she confides in him
and wants to escape with him anywhere
else but he reveals to her that his
battlefield isn't any better and that
she too should return to her own
in the story it brings to the forefront
of our minds sometimes you can't be
happy sometimes there are no happy
ending sometimes all we can do is
continue to struggle and fight
he disappeared into the darkness and in
the end i still didn't know who he was
just like when he appeared he took the
demons away
i was the only one left behind
i still don't really know what these
past days of fear sadness and shock were
to me
the mist cleared away
the mist that would never go away was
pushed out by the flames the clear sky
now peeks through
but it's by no means a spectacle that
makes my heart leap
like when i flew in the sky with rosine
it's
savage
lonely
cold
but
such a vivid sky
it's a clear sky
like the kind after a storm blows
through
i don't have wings so
i guess i'll look up at the sky and
crawl along the earth
maybe i can change something
the poetry in lost children's closing
chapters are a poignant and bittersweet
reminder that well comfort can be found
in fantasy and delusion the clear vivid
and real skies we seek so desperately in
life come at the expense of what we
thought it was we wanted sometimes your
most desperate dreams are destined to be
just that but you have a choice to exist
in the real world and appreciate what
you have when you have it or to lose
yourself like rosain in the delusions
and desires she had for the impossible
in this arc miura really does explore
themes of escapism through delusion the
story of rosine is one of tragedy and so
too is jill's a tale of tragedy with one
discernible difference jill's tragedy is
one of possibility one that contains
hope for the future and in the end if
berserk has taught me anything it's that
while things can get worse they can also
get much better and that alone is worth
struggling for both rosine and jill seek
ways to escape their realities burdened
with a feeling of not belonging having
grown up in families they don't feel a
connection with both rosin and jill see
themselves as picaf in his tale and
their respective journeys reflect his
actions in that children's story but in
slightly different ways ways that
explore the messaging of this arc in an
intensely effective fashion rosine
creates her nightmarish paradise filled
with the fake friends and guardians she
was denied as a child while jill asked
guts to take her to look for another
paradise once the action and events
subside in both cases guts is the one
who gives them their respective reality
checks firstly by killing roseanne and
forcing her to see what is real and
secondly by showing jill the reality of
what she's asking for the nightmarish
demons that haunt him every single night
there is no paradise only battlefields
and by accepting reality jill ends up
seeking her own way to confront her own
life's numerous obstacles and her own
destiny the same way guts does for a
manga so rife with conflict and
grotesque acts of violence and
misconduct the berserk series has
surprised me by reliably providing some
of the most perfectly poetic moments
like guts's heart-to-heart with jill at
the end there is no paradise for you to
escape to
what's there is just a battlefield
another friendly reminder that even the
most powerful or monstrous among us face
struggles only they can fully appreciate
and understand and that we are all in
one way or another struggling our own
way through life it should go without
saying at this point that quintaro miora
is a league into and of his own when it
comes to the condition of his layouts
and the presentation given to these
stories he's so feverishly lavished with
his deepest considerations rosine's
death is an absolute highlight from this
section and another reminder that while
he's immensely talented at depicting
some of the most horrific tragedies one
can conjure in their mind is also able
to elicit an ethereal and otherworldly
tragic beauty also i took a slightly
different direction with this arc and i
thought the inclusion of a fairy tale in
this story was an interesting angle for
which to tackle the material and to be
clear this is the main reason why the
more bombastic aspects of the story like
the fight with guts and the bandits that
were later turned into insects or
details like rosine having already shown
off her control over bug demons in the
golden age arc didn't take the main
focus of this video and speaking of guts
and rosin the final bout between the two
of them is brutally fantastic but as you
know the element that always receives
the main focus from me is the story
storytelling over action and because we
are now out of material that has a
companion anime my editor now only has
manga panels for which to create visuals
and thus making these videos has become
a much much more time-consuming effort
and pretty much like i did last time
with the character of zod i'm saving my
thoughts on the holy iron chain knights
for the second part of the conviction
tale as i have a feeling we're gonna see
much more of them later in the story but
in closing if you haven't read berserk
yet please do so it's honestly a story
unlike any i've read next week i tackle
my next white whale in the anime and
manga world and i hope you all can join
me on that big adventure but until then
i've been told not mark i'll see you all
next week and thank you so much for
watching
[Music]
you